the fight against coronavirus means that
everyone is talking about vaccines
but how do vaccines work and what have
ferrets got to do with it many human
diseases
like 19 are caused by tiny particles
called viruses
and by tiny we mean really really tiny
much smaller than a human cell
a lot of viruses have spikes on the
outside that are made of protein
the protein spikes help the virus to
attach to a cell
and eventually break into the cell where
it can do the real damage
this is what makes us ill luckily
when a virus manages to get into our
bodies
we are not left defenseless special
cells
circulate in the bloodstream and hunt
down viruses
and other things that can make us ill
these cells are part of the immune
system
two of the most important are called
phagocytes
and b cells phagocytes
destroy other cells the name actually
means
cell eta b cells
make the protective antibodies that kill
particular viruses
and other diseases when viruses get into
you the phagocytes seek them out and try
to engulf them
when the virus particle is completely
engulfed
by the phagocytes it is broken up and
destroyed but the phagocyte
doesn't throw away all the bits of the
virus straight away
it keeps the viral protein spikes the
thing the virus uses
to attach to your cells and
it shows them to the b cells
the b cells can now start to make
antibodies
which are a perfect fit for that
particular protein spike millions of
these antibodies are released
into the blood the antibodies stick to
the virus so it cannot
attach to your cells any longer
once b cells have made antibodies for a
particular virus
they will usually remember it for a long
time if the virus comes back
the b cells make more antibodies
straight away
before it can hurt you this is called
immunity vaccines work
by teaching your body to make antibodies
without having to meet the real virus
so scientists take the virus or one very
similar to it
and remove the parts that you damage
which is
usually the genetic material or dna
what is left is a depleted virus
something that cannot hurt you but which
still triggers
the b cells but how do you make sure
that the depleted virus really can't
hurt us
that's where ferrets come in vaccines
have to be tested
on something that has an immune system
to see if it is safe
and effective
ferrous are useful for studying flu-like
viruses
because they catch colds like humans and
have similar symptoms
but many other animals are essential
in the hunt for new vaccines especially
the laboratory mouse which is the most
commonly used animal
in science by far
even chickens help save lives the
viruses we study
are often grown in chicken eggs another
essential part
played by animals in vaccine research
in countries all over the world animal
studies
are an important part of the search for
new vaccines
for coronavirus and other conditions
this benefits people and animals
everywhere
you